i counted kind of four ways i'm sure
someone's like oh there's a fifth way
buddy no i counted four ways that i
think relationships can go so like the
husband's the boss
and the wife is kind of the partner i.e
jeff and mackenzie bezos well obviously
they're not together but she's cleared a
couple billion in her name now but then
you got like lebron and savannah james
he's the man she's clearly the woman and
he's you know he just became a
billionaire by the way today breaking
news lebron billionaires we all knew was
going to happen first first billionaire
athlete i believe yes
yes yes yes wow and then you know
another couple barack and michelle obama
right you might even want to throw
donald trump and melania in there right
clearly one's
the head of the household and one is
there to support okay so that's that
number one number two kind of like your
rito
yuri hex is saying
is maybe the wife's got her own thing
look at and uh j lo and uh a-rod or j-lo
and uh ben affleck or j-lo and uh mark
anthony jlo and basically everybody that
she's with yeah you've got will smith
and jada smith will more successful but
jada successful in her own right
and you know kim and kanye that's kind
of a thing and then obviously the johnny
depp amber heard thing so
but the woman is kind of has their own
success that's number two
then
very unique but out there
the woman is the breadwinner and the guy
stays at home i i have zero case
examples of that in the in the uh pop
culture atmosphere but it is a real
thing
i could tell you my friends who do that
but you don't want to know my friends so
that's the thing
and then the last thing is the good
housewife the ally and the pearl that we
had on last week where their role is
being focused on being the housewife so
if those are the options and there might
be a fifth what have you what is the
ideal role for you guys matt you want to
take this the first one is the partner
my wife is my partner she's my partner
in business she's my part in my life
she's a partner in her family every role
she's a partner in there's so many
things that i've
tried to make a decision on and if i
didn't defer to her so what do you think
about this scenario what are you
thinking because i'm about to do this i
don't know are you sure because i was
about to go 100
it went opposite
i was thinking and guess what it saved
me time energy and prevented me from
burning some bridges because was that
women's intuitive nature is that she's
business savvy what do you owe that i've
learned to trust coming from my mother
my sister the women in my family i've
learned to trust a woman's discernment
of being able to look at a different
perspective of things because i know me
the the the the guy me the you know i'm
i'm the marine alpha male dude yeah
let's kick down some doors right right
and uh let's let's let's blow this up
right whatever man let's do it but that
might get you into
a lot of trouble and there's a lot of
aftermath that goes along with that um i
tried uh looking at sheena as a
housewife and she
before we got married we're trying to uh
uh establish expectations uh you know we
were dating i said babe before we
continue forward i want you to know all
my garbage i remember italian restaurant
put in you know the italian restaurants
they put like a like a
white paper
clear the table boom this is my mar this
is my mess this is my garbage let me
mark it up so five tables later
right and there's my garbage it's a mess
i'm a i'm married divorce bankruptcy all
this stuff you put it out there put it
out there and it's nice why'd you put it
on because you know because i i felt
that the
relation was going really well
and i'd be hard i'd be heartbroken to
know that if i didn't tell her right now
and i waited and then it got so good and
i felt like if i let her down
it's over with gotcha you know how long
in were you in a relationship with her
before you made that decision today i
was
that was uh six months nine months okay
so but it took you some time to be like
look here are my cards on the table yeah
yeah and then vice versa she did and
then and then for six to nine months i
didn't bring it around but i didn't
bring around the business and bring
around the office no i'm dating for my
personal life
and then the more i did it listen you
know i really love what i'm doing i want
you involved and you're probably to come
out of the office anyway and i want you
to see who i'm involved with i want you
to get confidence with and she's like i
really like what you're doing says are
you sure you're like insurance you like
spreadsheets well i've got a degree in
finance are you sure because she's
competitive too she's because she played
softball in college yep and she does
things that i was doing that i thought
was i was great at she does a whole lot
better than i do with less experience
like what being the insurance agent hmm
right so i could be more of the
recruiter and she could be more like
correct i'm more of the results the
correct more relationship like we'll
start of a conversation she'll just get
right down to the numbers yeah i when we
we're in the boardroom i start with the
relationship
and she like oh man so you guys got a
great yin yang thing going on is what
you're saying okay so you're picking
option one respect to sheena by the way
if we don't know if you don't know who
matt's wife is she's a total g
like i've seen her speak at company
events like
nobody's paying me to say this i'm just
letting you know sheena's a g um derek i
gave you those options right do you have
one in mind
what you would say what you like
i would say the option where
that puts a man in more of a leadership
role
i would i would say option one yeah i
believe
um puts the man in the leadership role
because where would the women be though
would she be
like a partner to you or she'd be more a
housewife to you or
uh
essentially essentially she's
whoever you want her to be in a sense if
you if you if you would want her to be a
housewife
and she wants and she wants that role as
a housewife you know she'll be a
hospital whoever you you want her to be
or whoever she wants to be i would say
yeah because there's a difference there
whoever whoever you want you want her to
be because if she doesn't if she doesn't
want to to do that or be that then i
would say the relationship is is not
good because that's what you're looking
for that's what you want if you if you
want a housewife you're going to you're
going to look for hey i want a house so
if you want a partner you'll be like hey
i want you to be a partner so either or
that man would still be in a leadership
role um would you expect your wife to
cook clean do the laundry
all that stuff
if if if i told her if i'd be okay with
that yeah i'll be fine with that
i wasn't okay with that you were not
okay with that why
okay cause i can hire people for that i
was just about to say it's a waste of
time why would you want to
cook or i mean it's great for the kids
because what if she wants to do that for
you no that's amazing if that's what she
wants to do but if it's a partner and
you are actually going to do a goal
together yeah cleaning there's no time
for that but you have to pay somebody to
clean or cook or
do your laundry and that's exactly what
we did good job so yuri what role would
you do you see yourself of those four i
have to correct you because you said the
second but i actually fall very much
into the first okay um i left my
business and kind of my life for my guy
because um i saw the leadership and the
role that he was bringing and that's
exactly what i was looking for right so
why would i want to waste my energy in
things just to bring
money into the house
so
um after we figured that out well he had
figured it out and with his help he made
me
think and kind of i agree with you that
right if the guy makes it available to
you like through his leadership it's
very easy as a female to
um to bring your femininity yeah can i
ask you a question of course do you
think in your head that you have a
mental clock i got to get married by
this age no
no not at all i think i
marriage is just like something that
it's
i believe in it but it's only for the
government right
if me and my partner aren't doing well
like why do i need a license or why do i
need something that
solidifies what i have um i think that
yes we do have a clock as a female i
mean you know i would have to have kids
by a certain age
but um i don't think as far as like oh i
need to get married by this time now
like
got it it's natural to me maybe not to
my family and where i come from but to
me i just think and i've made it
i've made my parents understand that
to me there's more important things than
having those little labels like right
now i want to help to
have a better world so my children can
be in a better world but there's so many
other priorities i have
[Music]